I met him once when I did Letterman and
he I mean driver tell you that story
no I don't know my god alright so he's
the other guest no I'm going so I'm
going up to 2013 my mother's downstairs
like you know right when you go on he
heats commercial break and he goes ooh
you have on a beautiful suit and I yeah
and I was like oh that's nice my mom's
right there and my mom's going out to
John Travolta and then he he goes what
do you do and I said comedy and then he
puts his hand on my chest okay like
right away on my check everything put
sand on my chest and he's like it
heart's beating so fast I was like well
you have your hand like on my nipple is
that what you said I can't yeah we
should have your hand up above my nipple
and he like gave like a polite little
laugh but then just eye contact just
locked in with me and then he goes why
are you nervous I was like I've never
done TV before I've never done this and
he goes well no you have it's over
already you've actually done it I was
like no I'm going on next and he was
like no but you have to understand all
the verification process you have to go
through how many times you've practiced
this the actual work is done he was like
so I'm gonna sit here and watch these
five minutes for you because it's my
it's monumental in your life so that
means it's monumental in my life because
I feel like we're connected through this
heartbeat I'm putting my hand on your
chest and I feel your connection he goes
and I'm gonna sit here and watch every
second of this and I'll be here when you
get off and I calm me down so much when
he had helped you
it really did it calm me down and then I
go out do the set it was the best set in
my opinion that I've had of my work do
you call your Travolta set my Travolta
on TV I was locked in felt great I'm
coming off he's not there and I'm like
my life John Travolta he goes he left
immediately he was like as soon as you
said hello he left I was like wow yeah
he calmed me down right you know yeah he
had a nice moment with him nice moment
my him my mom said you know my mom was
like you know thank you so much for
talking and my son and he just didn't I
mean he was he was like if you're not a
guy I'm not interested
he's only because you think he was
thinking on you and not hitting on your
mom I wouldn't say he was hitting on me
right he was I mean he put his hand on
my nipple which I don't I don't my like
but he may just be a spiritual guy he's
Scientologist you don't know how they do
stuff that Scientology stuff was good
what's his prime met him like sign here
but I didn't talk to him like for more
than a minute what's his energy like
when you're talking to like he's he a
passive a charisma or a powerful energy
he has that presence and I don't know if
it's because we already know
John Travolta but he did feel like a
different he did I was like I was
talking to someone who's different I
felt the same way when I met Tony
Robbins
but I'm right just because I know who
these guys are and they are powerful but
like did he go like this I'm not your
[ __ ] guru no I didn't have that
energy though some guys have a weird
energy where it's like you get why
they're famous or you get why they're
movie stars that's what happened with
John Travolta I was like I get it I get
it
well you have legend at that moment I'm
glad he put into you what you needed to
have that Travolta set yeah and you've
never interacted with him since
I've never interacted with him since it
did nothing for my career um but you
know what are you gonna do one more Jim
and Sam catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM app
[Music]